hallo meine lieben und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video von mir
ihr wie auf den leib geschrieben dass
hier mal wieder gerne ein labor hättet
und euer wunsch ist mir befehl denn es
geht hier natürlich niemals um fordert
placement oder affiliate links sondern
einzig und allein um euch meine
community meine familie ich liebe euch
und deswegen zeige ich euch jetzt ganz
viele produkte die ihr kaufen könnt wer
kennt das nicht jeden tag ist man im
labor und jeden tag hat man das selber
an nehme ich einen weißen kittel und
eine schutzbrille nur wie kittel und
schutzbrille tragen müssen heißt das
noch lange nicht dass ihr langweilig
aussehen müssen wir anerkennen und so
guten alten rucksack
wir sind die handschuhe auf den boden
gefallen das lasse ich drin das wird
menschlich ich meine blaue handschuhe
passen das finde ich gut zu einem weißen
kittel
ja ich verstehe ich und dass das die am
meisten verkaufte farbe ist aber ganz
ehrlich leute langsam jetzt ein bisschen
langweilig der herbst 2017 steht im
namen von knalligen farben passt haltet
euch fest
ist das nicht toll so soll ich habe mich
an wie das mit dem titel aussieht und
wenn ihr denkt dass taschen pulver hier
kommen meine absoluten liebling
handschuhe leute matschie labore haben
ja diese lilian handschuhe die sitten
eine nette abwechslung aber ganz ehrlich
nichts geht über kick natürlich sind
alle diese handschuhe aus lille das
heißt sie lassen art zu tun durch damit
euer nagellack auch immer schön zerstört
wird wie es sich gehört wenn ihr jetzt
aber doch mal mit größeren mengen säure
arbeitet oder besseren schutz vor allem
gebraucht habe ich leute ist es nicht
schön brot ist nicht ganz so meine farbe
das muss ich sagen aber ich dachte die
sind trotz findet weil die so viel von
den weißen kittel dann auch verdecken
und ein bisschen mehr farbe ins labor
bringen wenn ich die praktischen
handschuhe also frei motorische arbeiten
sind nicht ganz so einfach aber was tut
man nicht alles für den richtigen look
machen wir weiter mit das ist die brille
die ich jetzt schon länger benutze das
problem hierbei ist für ihr vielleicht
schon bemerkt hat ich habe keine nase
da ist eine leichte erhöhung mit zwei
atemlos drin aber eine richtige nase ist
es nicht ist kann ich das gut dass ich
alle zwei minuten denn je macht nanny
auch eine zarte nase gehabt hab ich was
ganz tolles für euch und zwar diese
schutzbrille ist mit einem gummiband
verdient so kann nichts mehr verrutschen
aber ihr kennt mich ich mag es gern ein
bisschen extravaganter deswegen leute
schaut euch diese schönheit an das ist
natürlich auch ein ganz toller schutz
für ein full case of make up tv spots
zeigen die das in kombination mit dem
gelten handschuhe aussieht nämlich klar
ist wir niemals und papua denkspiel
immer selbst könnt ihr natürlich auf
aldrin vom fliese kombination rotten
alle links zu diesen wundervollen
produkten gibt es natürlich wie immer
unten in der video beschreibung und wenn
ihr beim checkout den coach in schleiz
20 verwendet kriegt sie alles 20 prozent
günstiger
freunde der sonne dass ihr sollte
natürlich kein shade oder hate sein für
meine kollegen aus beauty und lifestyle
ist ja alles nur ein spaß auf diesem
kanal geht nicht immer alles mit ernsten
dingen zu was ich eigentlich damit sagen
wollte ist schön schlau als wissens
kanal könnte von werbung nur sehr
schlecht leben im wissensbereich ist
halt nicht so große geld sage ich mache
mir wirst vielleicht schön schlau ist
eine winzige produktion sind ein
zweierteam ich produziere die meisten
videos einfach bei mir zu hause
das macht es natürlich zu einer
günstigen produktion aber neben ganz
viel herzblut fließen auch sehr viel
zeit und sehr viel arbeit in diesem
kanal und wenn diese zeit und arbeit
nicht bezahlt werden würde dann könnte
ich mir diesen kanal als creator einfach
nicht leisten deswegen möchte ich mich
hiermit bei euch allen bedanken für eure
gebühren
dann ganz ernsthaft gäbe es funk nicht
angebe ist ziemlich sicher keine
werbepartner die diesen kanal
ermöglichen würden zumindest keiner
hinter denen ich mit gutem gewissen
stehen würde und ich kann es ziemlich
gut verstehen falls er die gebühren
wo findet aber nichtsdestotrotz möchte
ich mich auch bei euch aufrichtig
bedanken dass ich jetzt seit über einem
jahr schön schlau machen darf also danke
für euren support auch wenn euch niemand
danach gefragt hat peace bleibt sicher
und wenn ich jetzt schon eine lanze für
funk breche unter dem hashtag scheiß
währung dann möchte doch wenigstens
selber werden für mich machen nämlich
folgen wir auch instagram facebook und
twitter